the tear gas gave the clue that
something was happening
a large group of people was approaching
the border with seota from the moroccan
side
we watched and waited and soon saw heads
bobbing in the water
the first group of around 20 swimming
their way into spanish territory
on the shore soldiers were waiting the
military drafted in after thousands made
this journey in the last few days
the swimmers were told to come ashore
and emerge
shivering and cold after their time in
the scene
all were male almost all young the fact
seemingly not lost on the military who
would soon take them to a local facility
but many have made it through this week
you see them everywhere close to the
border
new inhabitants of the streets of saota
we met these teenagers who evaded the
authorities
and told us of their journey to get here
this boy shows us the cuts he got on the
rocks
saying they were in the sea for an hour
another says they spotted the police but
weren't caught
thirty-year-old kareem from southern
morocco made the same journey
he didn't tell his family he was leaving
at this center the red cross is trying
to provide basic support to some of the
more than eight
thousand people who've made it to ceyuta
this week
including more than fifteen hundred
children and teenagers
they're given food and water and tested
for covid their future's uncertain
and like the many adults who've already
been returned to morocco
this spanish territory in north africa
is struggling to cope with the numbers
leaving many residents frustrated
i'm from morocco and i know my country
although i do live here in siota
people coming here are not looking for
jobs
it's a problem there's not the
infrastructure here to shelter so many
illegal migrants
foreign many locals are furious at
reports morocco relaxed its border
controls
following a diplomatic spat with spain
prompting this week's influx
but on this side of the border they're
taking an increasingly hard line
ceyuta has long been a focus for
migrants and asylum seekers from africa
trying to make it to europe
but the number getting in this week is
unprecedented spain has taken a hard
line already sending
thousands back and spain's border
problem is also
the european union's but from the
evidence we saw the presence of the
police and military is proving little
deterrent so far
and the worry is more people will try to
come over the summer months
michelle clifford sky news seyuta